oh small plates casual Chic Ambiance no
free soda refills Chickie's going on a
date
are you going on a date with Amy what no
why uh because you guys just kissed the
mission Charles we just kissed because
we were undercover that's it yeah it
didn't mean anything not that it's any
of your business Boyle but the person
that I'm taking on a date is a girl from
the gym what why is this the first time
I'm hearing about her or that you go to
the gym Jake avoid the weights nobody
wants you turning into another Terry hey
people like the way that I look sure
they do big guy
look I can't believe you're gonna take
some Fitness fluency to boost hey should
be going with Amy right Amy uh whatever
dog date the flues see it's never gonna
happen Boyle okay because I find Amy
repulsive and she finds me extremely
handsome so stop pressuring us oh you
sweet naive boy I haven't even begun to
pressure you two I've already written my
best man speech for your wedding
so how is the restaurant
being weird hey man I kissed what to
keep our cover from being blown we
didn't have a choice show me everything
Charles it was just a kiss okay it was
for work it was nothing yeah who cares
about a kiss call me if you grab each
other's asses
he's pulling over it's going down
you guys are so naive it's never nothing
in high school I played Daddy Warbucks
and Annie Becca MERS played Annie and we
were supposed to hug on stage at first
that seemed like nothing too but by
opening night we were full-on making out
as Daddy Warbucks and Annie the audience
was not on board play right through the
school guys guys it's not a handoff he's
leaving the package
okay you and Rosa follow Augustine right
and you and Amy follow your hearts no
we're gonna stay with the package and
each other forever come on man no no no
no no no no no Boyle can we please just
go to dinner no no no no no no no this
is not how you and Amy are supposed to
end you're supposed to grow old and die
holding each other as your cruise ship
slowly takes on water what do you want
me to say we tried really hard we made
rules we kept it light and Breezy light
and Breezy
how you describe a linen pants suit not
a relationship you care about we were
just being cautious cautious ow you guys
started this with one foot out the door
that's what Doom do not the universe
that actually makes a lot of sense
wow I was agreeing with you I'm sorry
I'm just so excited about all this all
right what do I do tell me easy you
march over there you tell her how you
feel and you bring a fancy bottle of
lavender shampoo because shampooing
woman's head is the most erotic thing
you could ever know no no shampoo that's
the worst but I am gonna go over there
I'm gonna tell her how I feel yeah you
go get her no wait till it starts
raining oh that's crazy go now okay
yeah sorry that's okay
I was home and I really wanted to talk
to someone about us and those are men
and about hope being gone and
then I realized that the only person I
want to talk about that stuff with is
you
so
screw just being colleagues and screw
light and Breezy right
definitely
guys we did it really did it
oh Charles is here listen guys Jake and
I were talking last night Pillow Talk
alert set the scene spooning or face to
face Charles
anyway we came up with a plan Jake is
going to befriend the vulture so he lays
off of us it's true I'm gonna bro down
with him if everything goes according to
plan we should be beer pong doubles
partners by the end of the week
ooh a lover's quarrel no I'm just tired
I didn't ask for part two never fear Amy
for I have the solution to all of your
problems highly potent liquid speed oh
you're gonna love that stuff Davenport
cops read the room but I know you'll be
excited because I busted Devin here with
four vials of this which is a new drug
called taxi you actually found some yep
your CI was right it's popping up on the
corners man my snitches are the best
send them handwritten thank you notes oh
so what do you say should we take this
partnership from the sheets to the
streets oh our first case is a couple
why not hey guys I just discovered a new
drug too it's called your relationship
and I'm high on it Charles somebody
needs to back off man Roger that her
purpose name is Carl ove I see I said
he's selling counterfeit caviar out of a
blue stall this place smells like a
squid farted instead of whales butt
yes that is the exact combo of smells
nicely done
hey next week is my six month
anniversary with Amy should I do
something special you know what I like
about our relationship Jake we don't
talk about our love lives or our
families or anything that's on our minds
it's why you're my closest friend in the
world yeah I know but I need help on
this I asked Boyle and he was useless
put a baby in her Jake what are you
waiting for
I don't know is anyone gonna buy it I
mean do I look pregnant I mean
I guess I can see it I think it's
amazing oh Jake and Amy and baby makes
three I don't know if I believe in God
but I have prayed for this that is
psychotic love it when everyone chance
that
so Charles and I really got into it on
the plane and around Sunday number five
I realized
we should move in together
you and Charles no you and me oh yes
that makes so much more sense absolutely
immediately let's do that
I love you so much
I love you so much too
this so much
so I guess Charles was listening to our
conversation yeah yeah oop I'm gonna get
this
hey
I never really got a chance to say hi
yeah
hi hi
oh my God everyone Jake and Amy are
going to kiss for the first time in six
months let those Nicholas Sparks Fly so
everyone's just gonna watch us yes get
to it you love birds
here we go come on man how did you get
there so fast love finds a way oh so I
know you're Jake's best friend did he
say that did you get that on tape no no
he didn't say that no you didn't get it
on tape it doesn't matter other way you
screwed up big time
anyway all I'm saying is I know you're
Jake's best friend and you really want
him to win this bed are you kidding
that's the last thing I want Jake moving
in with you is my dream come true your
apartment is two blocks away from mine
Jake will be able to pop by any time
imagine it
just had a tough day he's fighting with
Amy you know how you let things escalate
so just walks over to my place bottle of
wine in hand oh just talk it out and
then by the time that bottle's finished
you've come to your senses and apologize
maybe I don't want to win this bet I
love these thermal goggles Amy listen to
me very carefully if you and Jake are
thinking of trying you are ovulating
like crazy right now you'd take that
helmet off before I knock it off one
your basal temperature is off the
charged this is a good thing the auditor
will start by joining Peralta and
Santiago on their gang Stakeout because
here America's dream couple you need to
calm down we're in the workplace Sharon
can't pick him up because she's out of
town with Ava and the sitter doesn't get
to my house till 6 30. Jake and I can
pick them up absolutely a couple of
issues I don't have any car seats and my
rear window is technically a shower
curtain really why you know what does it
matter just take my minivan you got it
thanks guys I appreciate it
why are you doing that with your face
I'm smiling at Mommy and Daddy gross
picking up the Cagney and Lacey One
Taste of practice parenting and you two
will be so hot to have sex the kind that
make babies walk away Charles okay but
I'll be back in nine months have a dick
is Charles so ridiculous
maybe you should go talk to him about it
you know go to his house yeah
it's a good idea I'm gonna do that and
while you're talking to him
and Amy can babysit your kids unless
you're too busy making babies over there
I don't check it out get out of us but
also their little shoes are so cute
they're like little circles I know and
everything they hold looks so big
because their hands are so tiny yeah
they have to hold a cup of water with
both hands because they're so weak
one of my uncles long story go away
chicken Amy are getting married tonight
title of my sex tape what yeah all right
I got a lot more give me a half hour
whoa
wow you look beautiful thank you this
is the credible Gina this would have
been so crazy if you wore this to our
wedding I know
hey Amy I know I ruined your bear but I
made you a new one it's a shower curtain
uh yep Terry fumbled to task what we got
you a bouquet
wow that's gorgeous thank you where did
those come from well we should find a
florist in the city that was still open
and picked him up all right keep it in
your pants okay here we go Jake pay me
let's go downstairs
it's wedding time
here it is
[Music]
I really hope you like it but if you
don't I will kill myself Charles it
looks amazing it's beautiful how can I
ever repay you get pregnant use your
body to give the world more Jake holy
crap all right I'm gonna take Charles
away from you now I will see you up
there